all right now in this video we will
study the GABA receptor GABA receptor is
of two types the first is the gaba a and
the gaba receptor the gaba
a is a type of ionotropic receptor and
gaba B is a type of metabotropic or the
g-protein coupled receptor but in this
video we will only focus on the kappa
air receptor alright now first of all
let's see the structure of the GABA a
receptor I will try to make two views
the first is the front view and second
is the top view of the receptor coming
to the front view when the GABA a
receptor is pentameric it consists of
five subunits which are arranged partly
extracellularly and partly
intracellularly and these five subunits
are two alpha subunits two beta subunits
and one gamma subunit arranged around a
central pour now let's look at this
receptor from the top view consists of
the central chloride board and two drug
binding sites mainly consists of three
drug binding site but for the purpose of
illustration I have just drawn to the
first is the benzodiazepine binding site
and the second is the GABA binding site
okay now two alpha subunits two beta
subunits and one gamma subunit now
between the Alpha and the beta subunit
is the GABA binding site same as here on
the front view and same on the top view
and between the Alpha and the gamma
subunit is the benzodiazepine binding
site or the BCT allosteric site now the
next important thing I would like to
discuss is the mechanism of action of
this gaba receptor now the basic step
involved in the activation of the gaba
receptor is binding of a ligand or drug
to the gaba site or depends Reisman
binding site now due to this binding the
center chloride pore it opens up and
causes influx of the chloride ions which
further causes inhibition of the neuron
by creating a state of hyper
polarization in the neuron now let's
look at some of the drugs which act on
the GABA receptor the first of all I
would like to discuss the
gamma-aminobutyric acid or the gaba a
dis drug or it's and basically an
endogenous agonist of the gaba receptor
it is released at various sites in the
CNS and it acts on the table aside and
causes the same sequence of events we
have just discussed now the second class
of drugs that we will discuss are
grouped under as positive allosteric
modulator
now these drugs bind to the
benzodiazepine binding site and cause
the same chain of events
now in this category first of all we
have the benzodiazepines the diazepam
clonazepam these just act on the
benzodiazepine binding site they are the
positive allosteric modulator 'he's a
second class of drugs are the
barbiturates the thiopental and third
class of important drugs are the muscle
relaxants like biokinetic aside also
alcohol acts on this site and then we
have some anesthetic drugs like propofol
and etomidate there are some other drugs
but they are not that important as these
classes a third important category of
the drugs are the negative allosteric
modulator now there are a whole bunch of
drugs which are known as negative
allosteric modulator but the one I would
like to like you to remember is
flumazenil now this very important drug
it blocks the bezzerides being site or
you can say that it is a negative
allosteric modulator of depends what I
spin site now this drug is given in
pencil angela has been overdose and also
it is given in the reversal of the
anesthesia
now let's look at the effects of
activation of the GABA receptor now the
various drugs which act on this receptor
produce numerous effects some of which
are Angeles's anticonvulsant effect the
sedative effect partial amnesia and
muscle relaxation so this was a short
review of the gaba receptors function
and structure I hope you liked the video
if you find the video informative please
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe to my channel also I will make
a 3d model of the gaba receptors soon so
make sure to subscribe to my channel to
get an update on that video thank you so
much guys for watching